all right good morning i'm lieutenant
ray spencer i'm the homicide lieutenant
with the las vegas metropolitan police
department
i'm out here this morning to brief you
on a homicide investigation that we are
conducting in the 3600 block of
villanols east
which is a residential neighborhood in
the area of tropicana and pecos
i swear the details that i have right
now are very preliminary
however at around 4 15 this morning
officers responded on report of a male
who was shot
at the apartment directly behind me when
medical personnel
and police arrived that male was
pronounced deceased
on scene what we have learned is that
there is a woman who lives at the house
who had
got off of work this morning she
received a ride home from an
associate of hers when she arrived home
she asked that friend of hers
to escort her to the front of her house
because she was fearful
because there was a prior co-worker that
she had worked with that had been coming
around the house we're still trying to
figure out what the relationship
is between her and that prior co-worker
the
so the friend of hers walked her to the
front door
and when they were walking to the front
door they noticed the
male who's a white male who's 19 years
of age
i'll refer to him as the deceased that
male the deceased male
was walking towards them in a quick
manner
the friend and the female ran into the
house
and locked the door the deceased male
came up to the door
and fired around through the door which
caused the
friend of hers to shoot back striking
and killing the male
at the front door that male then called
911 so at this point it's still early on
in the investigation we are still trying
to determine
uh speak with witnesses who live in the
area and there's also video surveillance
that we're reviewing so with that i will
take a couple questions but it's still
very
who was shot to early is the male who
approached and then he called 9-1-1 and
passed away
no let me just clear clarify that so the
friend who is with the woman as they're
walking to the door they noticed
a man who walking quickly towards them
that man who was walking quickly towards
them is the deceased
apparently what we're gathering is he
was either
waiting in the area or just happened to
be in the area when the two of them
got home to the front door so when they
noticed him
they went inside locked the door and
that is when
that the 19 year old came up
tried to get into the house and shot one
round
at least one round into the residence
that caused the friend of the woman to
shoot back
outside striking and killing him
no the the per the two people who shot
are both males so the male who
shot the deceased
he's a male who's a friend of the woman
who lives at the house
is that the former co-worker do you know
that is the former co-worker
now we don't know exactly the
relationship she the
we're speaking with her now what we've
learned is that there was
a prior working relationship but
something had caused her to
be fearful that he was coming around to
the apartment